leur est au retrait du projet il y a
tellement d'autres sujets importants à
traiter nous insistons les citoyens
regarderont attentivement le vote de
chaque parlementaire répondez
positivement à leurs attentes
répondez positivement à leurs attentes
on est là pour échanger et alerter
s'il vous plaît on se calme on se calme
on débat on se calme on n'est pas on
n'est pas dans l'hémicycle de
l'Assemblée nationale s'il vous plaît
donc on se calme
on se calme on se calme on se calme et
maintenant la parole est Hakim monsieur
Beaugas
oui merci voilà
il y a eu le petit effet je peux je vais
je vais attendre
on est là pour débattre effectivement et
donc si vous nous avez si vous nous avez
invité
s de la remarque mais néanmoins nous
continuons le débat
non
moi je trouve que j'étais à la vanille
populaire les parlementaires quel que
soit le choix de leur vote ne fait pas
partie du débat démocratique point donc
mais jamais chacun le verra chacun
pourra le voir mais ce n'est pas c'est
une forme de menace je persiste des
signes mais néanmoins nous continuons le
débat je vous remercie voilà mais tout
le monde sait tout ce que tout le monde
vote donc il y a pas besoin voilà donc
c'est bon voilà donc Michel bogasse
après moi comme menace de me couper mon
électricité ou de menacer ma famille
envoyer des mails et des lettres de
menaces au parlementaire c'est
inadmissible voilà ce n'est pas le
sujet de
voix voilà donc monsieur bogaz vous avez
la parole
voilà merci madame la Présidente
[Musique]